[Music]
make fun cringe
I'm monogamous when a cup of crane is
together they are likely to stay
together for the rest of their lives but
unfortunately in my country Wanda
most of the cranes they hunted and sold
to people won't have the mini captivity
in their houses and hotels
and this means a huge number of cranes
does not get a chance to choose the
right partner we have started this
program where we are working with people
who have friends in a garden and they
are giving us those grants back here to
refine them to their natural habitat we
do continue to make sure they are
healthy because we mix cranes from
different houses we've seen some
eloquent like starting to bond
crying's like people day day and to
choose a partner it's a long process
cranes will start a series of calls and
then they start like bobbing their heads
up high and they will start doing a lot
of jump they jump in there and they call
together so in some cases they will just
fall in love on the first date oh they
have to try other before they find the
right one for life
you
[Music]
so our project is giving a second chance
to those acquaintances that's where once
in the captivity to choose the right
partner and contribute to the wildest
population of grape farm claims by
breeding and producing some chicks